[Music]
hi everybody thank you so much for
joining welcome to the r studio
enterprise community meetup
i'm rachel dempsey i'm sure i've met
many of you before at meetups like this
thank you for joining again
but for today's meetup we will learn how
the team at kpmg is scaling their data
science applications across the
enterprise
and working with front-end development
teams using microservices
in our studio connect
so tom will be kicking things off first
tom is a researcher and author on
applying technology data and analytics
to make better decisions
he's currently a managing director at
kpmg and previously served as the chief
data officer for the city of chicago
tom will get us going here and then turn
it over to bijan
bijan sadigan is a director of analytics
at kpmg and leads data science
development which spans from advanced
analytics to machine learning
engineering
i'm so excited to turn it over to both
of you thank you so much for joining us
today
well thank you very much thank you for
for having us here uh it is exciting to
talk about rn production i'm a long time
r user and developer it goes back to my
time in grad school when hadley wickham
and i were both at iowa state in grad
school
i was using early versions of reshape
and gg plots well before gg plot 2. and
so it goes all the way back to then
where it was a statistical language and
now seeing the language mature to talk
about being used in production and going
to talk about how we use uh r in
production at kpmg so i just want to be
clear kpmg is a consulting firm but this
isn't about what we've done for a client
or a use case that we're advocating for
this is how we are using our within our
environment and particularly about using
microservices and able to scale out data
science across the enterprise and the
reasons why we
opted to go down the microservices realm
and there's been meetups here and
there's been conversations elsewhere
talking about using shiny and how to
scale shiny across the enterprise and
the tactics and techniques to do that
which is absolutely a potential way of
doing it we've taken a different path by
trying to use microservices to be part
of the data science team and we're going
to talk about why we went down that path
the benefits that has provided us some
of the challenges that you should
anticipate to see when using
microservices and absolutely giving you
at least a couple of demos today to show
how this actually works in production so
i'll hop back i'll hop right into it and
then bijan will take over for a good
chunk of the conversation and and
hopefully have a good uh good
opportunity for q a at the end of this
presentation
so as i mentioned we're going to talk
about a few things six things in
particular
what are the challenges of growing a
data science team i've built a number of
data science teams at this point in the
commercial sectors i do today i've
worked in the public sector when i
served as chief data officer for the
city of chicago so talk about the
challenge and trade-offs of what it
looks like to grow a data science team
and why microservices start to enter the
equation
second talk about microservices what are
they exactly
there's a lot written on the topic of
microservices i've got a couple of my
favorite
textbooks here that i have read around
the concept of microservices and then
we're going to dive into a demo a hello
world very simple example of a
microservices
then talk about how to plan and design
for microservices and and take a look at
a demo
an application demo and then finally a
time for q a and a recap
so
the challenges of and the trade-offs of
growing a data science team or what i
call is like how i stopped worrying
about hiring because this is something
as the team is growing you start getting
into his concerns about how do you scale
the applications and how do you scale
your team to work across uh one or many
different applications
so
as a guinea good presentation
we're going to summarize this as a graph
and so there's always this trade-off
that we have in our work as data
scientists or software developers
between complexity and what i just call
being hackish in terms of trying to
implement something and we probably have
all felt it we're working on trying to
do something that's more complex but
we're trying to do it without
hacking around being too
clever on trying to implement a solution
trying to back in engineering something
to make it work because that creates
long-term liability
you might be the only person that knows
how to deal with a particular
solution that you've built so in that
left upper left-hand quadrant there you
see that sort of programmer's lore where
you do a lot of complexity but you don't
do do in a very hackish way in the lower
right-hand corner that rube goldberg
zone of you're doing something that's
not very complex but doing an absolute
hackish way and that 45 degree line is
really that balance and trying to
recognize okay how do we do more complex
things again without being too hackish
on the solution and this is something
that bijan and i and our team think
about quite a bit how do we do our work
well is essentially what this summarizes
too so we're going to talk about how
microservices helps you
do things
things with greater complexity where
complex needs but without going into too
much of a hackish zone
so this is something that
we often see within growing our
analytics tool set so
as you see in those big bubbles we talk
about the progression of user needs over
time so when you build a data science
application or some sort of solution you
know
immediately you make folks happy you
make your data scientists happy you make
your developers happy because you say
hey
somebody needed something i got a
version one out there everybody's
everybody's fantastic and everybody's
happy and then
the user needs increase and sometimes
that's just okay need a few more graphs
okay there's more complexity more
interactivity that's needed uh there's
other things that need to be polished
nicer looking buttons uh then there's
things that start to kind of grade at
you like well i really like these graphs
can you have them so they can be
exported into powerpoint like okay
we can don't want to do that but sure if
that's what you was needed and then
after you get all that done
a user might come back to he's like
actually no my priorities were different
i need something completely different
and that's this is that progression
where you're trying to balance with your
data scientists on their happiness and
your developer team's happiness so
they can be engaged they continue
continue to get that satisfaction
working in projects and try to avoid
some of that grading aspects
on progressing and changing your your
applications and solutions over a period
of time
and when you do this in shiny there's a
number of different issues that pop up
one of which really is it becomes more
and more difficult to have multiple
developers on working on the same piece
of code
because the way the shiny applications
and the application structure tends to
work you tend to work on one or two
individual files now there's workarounds
to this certainly you can source other
files you can do other tricks but it
gets complicated over a period of time
so you might having two coders who are
trying to work on the same segments of
code somebody who's working on a very
large segment of code other people might
be work waiting on that other segment of
code to be done
and there's oftentimes just conflicts
that start to arise and we're going to
talk about a project today
that was getting to 15 000 lines of code
in shiny and it was creating a large
number of conflicts as the development
team was trying to work on new features
so
is led us to microservices if we take a
look at those different challenges and
and those balancing needs we want to
start talking about microservice so
we're going to describe this at a high
level and then we're going to dive into
it quite a bit and i will say there will
be a forthcoming blog post that dives
into the technical details a lot more
but so we're going to address this at a
cursory level for a period of time
so in short this is a very in short
version of it microservices really helps
separate out the different layers of an
application so there can be a web or
user interface uh that allows somebody
to navigate information but that's
separate from the underlying logic of
the application where in the case of
shiny those things get
mashed together into a same or what we
call monolithic code structure
because it separates it out because
underneath that interface you have a
series of apis or web services
restful apis things like that that allow
you to build apis that control that
interactivity so when somebody's
clicking on a on a something in a web
browser it's communicating via apis
behind it and behind those apis is a
data storage or database technology that
allows you to uh to query and bring in
data and that separation between the
user interface and the apis and web
services helps simplify your code
structure and also allows different
people to work on the same bits of code
and the reason why we're talking about
this here today
is because
that web interface and those apis and
web services can be completely hosted on
rstudio connect our studio connect
basically is
a a web server and you can host
web files on there if you upload
index.html it will it will render that
in in addition to shiny and everything
else so it allows us to host things such
as a react or angular or other web
technology within the rco connect
environment for us we use the react
technology
and again that's uh hosted on top of
apis and web services which could be
done in either plumber which we have
done on our team or using flask in the
python language
so what is a simple example of a micro
services look like let's say let's say
we have a bunch of time series data and
we want to do a forecast of that time
series data and you're actually going to
see a demo of this here in a moment
but to explain the architecture uh you
have data that's holding on to
historical time series information so
all those entries about historical uh
historical interviews for the time
series
then you have in our model let's say
it's an arima model that can do the time
that can do the forecasting uh that is
written by data scientists and then on
top of that you deploy apis and web
services that communicate back to that
analytical model that in turn
communicate back to that database that
will actually do the forecast
and then that forecasted data is then
presented up to the web uh to the
website or the dashboard that allows the
the user to see that in a visual format
and so the reason why we separate that
apart is because then the front end that
that user interface can be developed by
an independent web developer or a full
stack developer and you can have web
designers working on that so you don't
need to hire that shiny developer
anymore and focus on that very
particular skill set but be able to
bring in uh web development technologies
that are more broadly used in other
environments as well
meanwhile the web services can be
programmed by your data scientists
because it can be done in r the python
language in addition to the data
engineer or backend developer or other
full stack developers to be able to
build out those web services and again
this is in contrast to a shiny
application architecture where really
that front end and all that logic a lot
of times is buried in the shiny piece of
the application and so that restricts
the number of individuals who really can
do work on that piece
and the takeaway of why this is so
beneficial it really allows that front
end
development technology to flourish
because you can tap into the entire
ecosystem of development technologies uh
that that can be brought to bear with
your web developers
so
i talked about a time series example and
so it'd be great to then share an
example actually take a look at code
base of what does that look like what
does microsoft services look like
within an application using a very
simple hello world example and for that
bijan is okay if i turn it over to you
absolutely yeah i will uh take it on
from here like tom mentioned uh this is
a very simple demonstration of a a
microservice that would do some
prediction i'll get into a little bit of
the details of the back end
in a second
um but
this took not more than a day to put
together um the front end is in a react
application and the backend is hosted on
rcu connect using plumber
this demonstration is pretty simple uh a
user would come in they would say i want
to see
a forecast of some time series data over
the next 48 periods um we'd hit submit
what's happening now is the client side
is making it across our studio
connect to our api
uh it's making that prediction with our
pre-trained model and then it's
responding with all of that information
um the benefit of having those two
separate as opposed to having shiny kind
of handle it all at once is that shiny
has to render the front end and do the
computation on the back end that's fine
for one person
but when you try to scale things that
puts a lot of load on the server um
having this separation lets the client
side do some like calculations and
rendering and then the heavier
calculations on the back end
again very simple demonstration of
what microservices can do one thing that
i want to
also kind of call out here is that one
of the benefits of having them separate
like this is that you can actually touch
the back end without the front end uh
just a quick question b john if you
could zoom in a little bit
when you flip over to the other one
yeah
i'm not sure if i can zoom in on this
one though uh
i'll
just speak to it briefly so
um i'll get into a little bit more on
the testing which is what is using post
now which is what i'm showing here but
one benefit of a micro service back-end
is that you can touch those back end
points without having to go through a
web interface um
so one thing that i just did is i made a
prediction um but that prediction uh
service is actually calling another
service uh that does our logging
so i can also make a request and see
okay well i just made a request
two minutes ago um for a prediction um
just being able to touch the back end
and from different systems uh is a huge
benefit for uh microservices because you
don't have everything encapsulated into
one codebase
so what i'm showing here is the
architecture of that um relatively basic
uh
microservice app um so we saw the web
interface was which is a react um
based uh application uh and i made a
request to one micros one one service um
that does our forecasts
that service also made a request to a
separate service that handles all of our
logging
this may not it may not make sense to
you know why do you have these two
separate until you start thinking about
when you start building other products
you probably want to use the same
logging service
so you get that benefit of not having to
build in every single app
and instead call to this the one
instance that you have from every single
one of your apps
one example i can give you is about a
year ago we we had a fundamental change
to
our logging code where we were using
a package at the time
every single one of our shiny apps which
was roughly about 20 of them
had that code installed when they when
they were published to our studio
connect
when we had to make that change we
actually had to have all of our
developers pause their work
spend about two weeks
making that change in their code testing
out their code and then rely
republishing their applications every
single one of them
had we had a micro
logging service
it would have been as simple as changing
the one service doing the testing as
well but it would be substantially less
work
so that's the reason for the separation
and a good reason why you want to
to separate those duties instead of
having it all in one code base
and then the database
is very similar to shiny you would have
some sort of storage so that you don't
have your
your app
save data or put it on a file system
something like that
okay um so now i'll get into a bit of um
the lessons learned that we came across
while uh transitioning over to a
microservice architecture um about a
year year and a half ago we started the
first application um on this this type
of architecture so we were moving from a
monolithic
shiny application
as tom mentioned before it was the
application that grew to about 15 000
lines of code
there were some challenges with the
monolithic
architecture that
more or less pushed us into making a
decision of
do we do we make the switch now
so a year and a half ago we started that
switch and the intent of this part of
the presentation is to talk through
some challenges that we ran into and how
we overcame them
so uh there are four uh pretty
overarching uh challenges with uh
getting started with microservices and
the first one is
getting started with microservices can
be very daunting there's a lot of
material out there
microservices
are defined very similarly but slightly
different depending on what source you
look at
and on top of that planning for your
application
is really a very open-ended problem
because
you're
thinking of a service that could
potentially be reused in a future use
case that you have no idea about
and so what you want to do is you want
to plan for that service that's general
enough to where it could be applied in
the future and you wouldn't have to
change the interface
um at that point in time um but not too
general to where you're trying to build
for the world
um
on top of that because these services
can be used from
with different application different uh
user interfaces um it becomes a lot more
important to
define what that interface is
because if you if you do have to change
it in the future you have to go back and
you have to test all the older versions
or handle version control very carefully
um so
getting started is quite a challenge and
we'll talk to that a bit here
um
separation of developer duties um
comes with a lot of benefits because you
can hire for specialized skill sets but
at the same time coordination amongst
your team
is
even more important in that case
the application that we built
over the last year and a half was
actually a worldwide team from
literally all parts of the world we had
maybe a two-hour window of everybody
being online at the same time
um
and so we'll get into a little bit of
how we we overcame that challenge
in a second as well
the third thing here is that
microservices are great for
scaling things out um
but they do come with their own set of
risks that monolithic apps don't
necessarily have
i'll talk a little bit more about that
in a second
and then finally
the whole microservice architecture it
generally as a data scientist there was
a big knowledge gap there
the way to to kind of address that is to
attend meetups like this and
later take a look at our blog post but
do your own research as well data
scientists traditionally may or may not
know a lot about design patterns or http
requests so
there's generally some knowledge gaps on
top of that smaller teams and smaller
projects may um may not get as much of a
benefit out of switching to a
microservice architecture versus a
monolithic
app
just purely based on the fact that
microservices may take a bit more
upfront cost and if you're not planning
on reusing those services or have no
intent to ever reuse those services it
may be costs that you don't necessarily
want to take on
so that's a fourth challenge the cost
benefit of it is something to always
consider
so
how do you address getting started um
so one thing that we started with is uh
using domain-driven design if you search
microservices this is very commonly what
pops up first
um domain-driven design is using the
business
domain so knowledge about the business
to conceptualize what you actually need
to be building um and then you take that
and you build those um as entities in
your system um so i've listed some steps
here um the first thing is that you want
to identify your your entities in your
business domain um in this graphic at
the bottom left here
i've just put up a simple kind of
e-commerce sort of thing so you have
customers who are their own entity you
have products that are their own entity
and you have orders that are also an
entity
those are three entities in a very
simple system or a very simple business
the second step would be to understand
how those entities relate to each other
so customers will search for products
they'll make orders orders will have
products
relatively simple relationship but
the point of these two parts is to then
get to this this third part of
what services do you need to do what
what actions do you need to take on
these entities um so on the right hand
side here um for each one of the the
entities that i have i have um these are
uh
http um api uh verbs
um
so
you
you get a sense of okay for a customer i
need to be able to get the list of
customers i need to be able to create
customers i need to be able to edit
customers i may need to remove customers
and so that defines the the endpoints
that you individually would need to
create and those endpoints create that
service for customers
similarly on products you may not need
to be able to edit which is the put
request or delete
and so you may have a little bit less
work for products but again you create
that service for products
and then similarly for orders
um
the key point for this slide is that uh
following these three steps gets you uh
from this kind of wide open field to
these are what i need to be focusing on
there may be things around them but
these are the things that you need to be
focusing on
now going into the second part of
planning which is applying uh design
patterns specifically cloud design
patterns so i mentioned that these
entities in these relationships define
the kind of areas that you need to focus
on but there are things around them that
may pop up as well
that's what design patterns help you
identify so
there's plenty of material out there as
well on design patterns but three that
we've used um are known as side card
patterns um anti-corruption layers and
uh back-ends for front-ends
what these do is they categorize your
services that may not necessarily apply
to products for example
but may serve your a very particular
front end that needs to know what you
know the list of products or have
products formatted in a very certain way
you can write a service that that
services that front end specifically a
lot very commonly we have websites that
are designed for web and mobile
and they
unfortunately have some differences
being able to write a service that
supports each one or handles one versus
the other
helps you kind of abstract that out of
having one service handle too many
things
um
similarly side cars are things like the
logging service that i pointed to
earlier they're things that your
application or your your client will
never touch
but they're things that you're
back end architecture will touch or
things that are used behind the scenes
that are never never seen by the user
um
the third one here is anti-corruption
layers i bring this up because while we
were switching over from
a monolithic app to
a microservices app
there was a transition we had to take
we had a legacy system that we had to
interface with our newer
newer application anti-corruption layers
are designed for that this
the intent here is that you serve
from the legacy system to your new apple
your new application but you don't have
to include that kind of information
inside of your app services
the idea micro services starting with
micro is that you have them very
specialized um doing one thing very well
but have logical separation to where
one service is not stepping over another
service
um the next part here is uh
separation of development duties so um
i'll just go into a bit of what we did
so we defined um a very uh structured
documentation
um
format for uh every one of our endpoints
um or every one of our services
um and we also uh utilize swagger pretty
heavily so
um
a lot of this will be coming uh these
details will be coming in the blog in
the future
but to go at a high level
um
every single endpoint that we built that
comprises a service
started with documentation this exact
documentation on the right here
and the intent was to have front-end
back-end every developer on the team be
on the same page and know exactly what
is going to be
the interface
um like i mentioned before if you change
the interface everybody else has to
change the work that they're doing if
they're touching that
and so establishing that up front was
crucial for us to to be effective
um we found that uh this kind of format
helps in a lot of ways because we define
what's required both in a request and a
response or what comes back in your
response as well as types
and an example generally helps uh go a
long way
on top of that
one of the great things about plumber is
that it builds your swagger
documentation automatically
and so
while you're building your micro service
uh
you can kind of validate what you're
building or anybody can validate on the
team what you're building
against the documentation they just
simply have to go to the
url on art studio connect and click on
the right
endpoint
okay so the third part here is talking
about how to manage the
the newer risk that comes with
microservices
so one of the big risks of microservices
is that they can be distributed a
monolithic
architecture is generally one virtual
machine or one machine that's running
everything so
um
the you know all of the calculations for
the backing for the front end are all
from the single node um a micro service
could be on a lambda cert a lambda
function it could be on another virtual
machine it could even be external to
your company it could be
using a third-party
api that serves for a certain reason
all of those come with risk because
every degree of freedom you give to your
system will introduce a potential
you know failure point
and so being able to do functional
testing and regression testing um easily
is crucial um and
the you know microservices and apis
being a very fundamental thing to the
web
there's a lot of
supporting uh documentation and software
that will help you do this um i showed
uh postman earlier today um postman is
what we used for every single one of our
endpoints every
endpoint that we developed um we
during our pull requests reviewed the
test as well made sure we
had you know adequate testing adequate
coverage um and made sure that it was
working when it was supposed to work and
then cause you know
forced failures when we were supposed to
force them
um
postband is also great for um performing
schema tests as well um that's something
that's uh in a loosely typed language
like r or python um it's not uh
not very common to to check your
variable type or if you do it kind of
clutters up the code
postman will actually can do uh schema
tests as well so you can expect a number
when
you can test if there's a number when
you expect it
and finally the last point here um i
don't have a slide on but the point um
being is that there's a lot of research
out there even you attending this meetup
today is a step in this direction
filling in those knowledge gaps and
considering the costs and benefits
um so i
just want to call that out as that's
that's something that
if there's some overhead with micro
services there's not a lot and there is
multiplicative benefits in the future if
if you start reusing these services
but for each team it depends on the size
of the team
the amount of
repeatable work that you do
as well as the knowledge gaps that you
want to overcome
so now i'll switch over to uh
a demonstration of the application that
we built um using microservices
this application is called coda it's the
kpmg organization design analyzer
app oops did i choose the wrong one
um so
coda is a tool for
users to be able to
analyze a company census so that the
entire organization
structure
there are a couple of views of the
organization that we provide and some
statistics as well
the intent is that you can do a quick
analysis if you need to
you can reorganize the the organization
if you see you know people that are in
finance reporting to people in sales
that may not be so efficient for your
organization
um
the intent of coda is to be able to
assess
organize
redesign um do some quick analysis um or
comparisons of your design uh and then
finally be able to ship to your your
customer
um so what i'm showing here is actually
the reason that we switched into a react
based front-end this is our what we call
a radio plot um and this is an
organization where the in this case the
ceo is in the center of the the org um
and then you know their direct reporties
are the next layer out and then the
reportees outside of that
um
doing this in shiny became quite
cumbersome and we'll talk about that in
a little bit
because you're working with two
languages that are kind of speaking
interchangeably within this the one
language
um
but coda allows you to do things like
for example if i wanted to select this
person and reassign them here um i could
reassign you know their entire
organization
everybody underneath them here as well
i can just do some simple things like
reorder these dots around
there we go
and i can do things like uh
well i won't run them here but we can
create cuts of the same visual um and uh
produce any number of charts because
generally our clients do ask for for
powerpoints um again this is a an
analysis tool so um the intent here is
to see i'm coloring by uh department uh
and you get to see so r d you know well
i can actually click on it so r d is
colored over here we see that this
person is
tends to
seems to be the lead of r d but there
are also um some people um over here
that maybe they they shouldn't be uh
managing or maybe we need to separate
that into another person um because it's
such a wide span of people
[Music]
i won't go into the details of every one
of the features there's some comparison
abilities as well
and then also just a relatively simple
dashboard that shows um you know your
organization at different levels broken
up by the departments that are at each
level
i didn't upload any compensation data so
it's not here
now if i go over to the implementation
side so this is where um users start to
make changes to the organization itself
um
and so uh
again same organization same ceo if i
wanted to um let's say i want to search
for
a certain person let's uh let's do
ferguson page
um
i would find uh her which would be
over here
and it's me to the right person oh here
um if i wanted to reassign them i could
move them to
this person here and so now i've i've
kind of modified the organization
um
also
you can you know add in new people to
the org um by clicking here just a new
person
um and
one of the features that i personally
love is the fact that you can actually
track all the history that you're doing
here and you know roll it back if i made
a mistake here i can
remove that
the
coda application
started as a shiny app
we
were embedding d3 visuals especially the
uh radial chart uh inside of the
application we actually had an instance
of this as well that i think was really
javascript not necessarily d3
but those two things um we started
getting into the habit of writing
javascript messages from the backend to
the front end to um
to lit to
trigger a callback to see you know if a
user clicked on this node
if the user clicked on a note here
what was the note like what was the um
piece of information that they were
looking for um so we were
a data scientist writing an r
writing in javascript to get this all to
work and so that's why we
transitioned over to have react
developers write this in javascript and
d3
but communicate to them using the
language that we know which is r
um
that was the the genesis of of code and
why we made this big switch um on top of
that uh the styling and everything was
was much easier to do
in a in a framework like that
the four screens that i'm showing here
uh i touched on the assassin design um
so the the radial chart and the design
of an organization um i i didn't uh go
into the compare the percent just um for
for time's sake but um
the the idea here or the intent to show
this is that um any of the visuals that
we have we have we have people with the
right skill sets doing this um
and the people like the data scientists
working within their um their own
professional uh areas as well uh it
makes for that that kind of separation
of duties makes for a lot faster
development because you don't have a
data scientist learning how to write
javascript
um
and then uh
just a very basic uh kind of application
level diagram of the application i just
showed coda um so very similar to the
simple demo that i shared earlier um we
have a react web app but we also um have
a power bi dashboard that interacts with
our microservice so i mentioned earlier
that microservices could be reused um
this is a perfect example of that power
bi is interacting with the same
microservice that our react is that
react app is
and so now we have two interfaces and
one um that we
that is quick to
we now have the opportunity to say okay
well we want to build this and react
because we need high interactivity um we
want to build this in power bi because
maybe we want to ship that out to the
client as a dashboard and so now we give
us the freedom to use the best tool for
the
the right problem or for the problem
i mentioned side cars earlier
similarly in our application we use that
for logging some user authentication and
for monitoring
and on top of that one um
additional uh kind of major benefit is
is being able to test
the endpoints either in the production
server or in a staging server
and we do that we do that regularly so
every single release that we do we test
the entire
entire set of services
and we do them
periodically as well
netflix actually
has an idea of a
chaos monkey which is
a testing node but a testing node
designed to try to find weaknesses in
your system um that's something on a
horizon as well the benefit of using
microservices is that you can
hit what your user would also get um or
a copy of that maybe not maybe not use
the production version
um and i'll step over this um just very
quickly but this is our just to connect
it back to
the
design
domain-driven design so these are the
entities and the relationships that we
have for our coda application
and we'll get into the details of that
but this is what we started with and
gradually built to to where we are today
so uh switching into now a recap um
tom would you like to take this one yeah
so going back to what we showed earlier
what is that trade-off between
complexity on users needing interactive
graphs uh
uh
which we're trying to do in d3 and
that's creating a lot of complications
just debugging that to being able to
export things into images into
powerpoint where these uh new things
were coming along and it was creating
some discord
within the data science team because
they're needing to learn more and that
just that's very taxing that's very
tiring so this allows us to
have folk people focus on front-end
technologies versus the data science
piece of it versus the mac and piece of
it so this is our path where we first
deployed in coda and other applications
that we have put as the example that we
use here that monolithic shiny
applications it allows us to do a lot
more complexity with not trying to hack
around that but then we got into
javascript messaging and then we got
into trying to get d3 to work within
shiny and then
it felt like we were doing too much
hacking around and over time we knew
that that was going to be a risk to the
maintaining of the applications
themselves so by switching over to
microservices uh back-end and react
front-end it allowed us to increase the
complexity of what the application was
asking for but get us out of that danger
zone of trying to hack things together
to be able to make it work if we can go
to the next slide bijan
you keep it you're controlling it so we
talked about some of the benefits so
those benefits is we allowed to that
division of labor and specialization
bringing people to focus on what they do
well
uh to be able to program a more advanced
user interface what you saw here running
today was all running off of rstudio
connect right so i think i think
subjectively qualitatively is a very
different looking thing than what people
typically expect to see running within
an r base largely in our base
application has multiple consumption
points developers can hit those apis
power bi bi applications can hit those
apis custom front-end applications can
other programs connect those apis so
people can consume those they're
reusable
and you're relying on a wider universe
of tools and libraries the our ecosystem
is amazing uh there's hexagons
everywhere that allow you to show
internet connectivity but all those are
really trying to wrap in some other
technology this allows us to directly
reach out to those other technologies so
again it avoids that sort of hackish uh
hackage region and as bijan mentioned if
there's a cost benefit there you just
need to see does this make sense or can
i rely on the
the shiny to our ecosystem exclusively
and also the python ecosystem
uh it becomes more code agnostic and
really allows you to adopt formal devops
procedures continuous integration
continuous deployment code versioning
gets all this is underlying everything
that we've talked about today because we
need you need to be able to do that very
well there i know there's a lot of other
presentations about how to use version
control and all that and those are
fantastic things to dive into
but bijan and the team we've mentioned a
number of challenges it does require
more planning there's a cost benefit is
for every project do we do pure shiny do
we do this micro services approach
requires the paramount
the strong team coordination so because
it's not all in one thing it's in
different pieces you just need to be
coordinated on those different pieces i
describe it as building a bridge
starting from both sides of a riverbank
you start on both sides and you need to
be able to meet in the middle and if you
don't that bridge is going to meet in
the middle and that's always what this
boils down to
and so there's a unique risk within
those distributed services and
additional skills and resources may be
required but if you're a growing team
this is kind of the point of it if
you're a growing team you can make hires
and front end development and other
specializations to allow them to really
flourish and focus on that again you're
you're looking at industry standard
technologies
i know we got one more slide but i think
we can really wrap it up where i think
we're two and a half minutes over for
what we're going for but uh thank you
for having us here today uh we're really
glad to contribute to the the ecosystem
of knowledge which is the art community
um uh hopefully this is helpful for you
i i we had to do a lot of research when
we're trying to implement this
themselves as we mentioned we'll do a
technical write-up as well to get into
some of the nitty gritty of what makes
us work versus not make it work uh but
rachel turn it back to you if we have
any time for a q a if there's any
questions yeah there are a lot of great
questions here but just want to say
thank you so much tom and bijan for an
awesome presentation it it's great to
see
apis and and microservices in action
um i always say we're all clapping you
can't hear us if we're all in the same
room he's clapping for you thank you so
much
i'll go over to slido and just a
reminder if you want to ask questions
you can use
the slido link and you can put your name
in and i could call on you or you could
just ask anonymously too
but one of the questions was
can you use an r shiny front end
together with a microservice back end
yeah i can take that if you want
something um yes the answer is yes so
you could use any
any front-end technology shiny is a
perfectly fine um front-end technology
as well um you would simply just be
making the same calls
that you know a python script or react
app app would do
awesome thank you
i see rahul asked a question on slido
and
we'll feel free to jump in if you want
to add any other
context too i'll allow let me let me fix
some of our settings here
but it was do you hire separately for
back-end data science development and
front-end shiny ui development
we do so we have a dedicated front-end
development team now so as the team grew
we separated the responsibilities of the
data scientists who originally did some
pieces of front-end development
we separated that out so now there's a
specialized front-end development team
that front-end development team both
consists of
uh
react-focused developers but also ui ux
designers so there's an entire suite of
design tools that are used to mock up of
how an application should look like
which is fantastic because instead of
having to program something to show a
user you can show them
wireframes or pretty pretty advanced
mockups and those can be immediately
exported into a structure of a web page
which allows the react folks to just
start populating everything so they
don't have to take that sketch and then
kind of say what color did you use all
that kind of automatically imports into
the html css that allows them to be able
to do our work and our data scientists
focus right now on two things one is api
and back-end development and then also
data science so they still have some
development components
that they do but they're programming in
r uh and soon now python we've been
focusing on r we're going to be doing
more python coming up uh allow them to
create those apis but also do the pure
data science work as well so we have now
separated those responsibilities when we
began we were a team of five
individuals we're now 45 individuals and
so as our portfolio has gotten very
large coda and two dozen other
applications uh that has allowed us to
separate those those functions
great thank you
let's see there's a lot of great
questions here um excuse me if i missed
this but are all microservices managed
by a centralized unit
um so they don't have to be um one of
the big benefits of microservices is
that you can launch them um in any
service that makes the most sense so
right now we do a lot on our studio
connect because it does a fantastic job
of not only hosting but load balancing
too that's a big reason why we were able
to move so quickly
um but you're able to use you know azure
functions
um
and again any sort of you know
third-party services law so if there is
a service that um you know your firm
decides to that is is more beneficial to
purchase and it's you know cheap enough
you can also integrate that into the
same
suite uh the micro services that you're
doing and you save yourself the headache
of developing it
so they don't have to be on the same uh
com compute node um they can be
as spread out as as it as it makes sense
awesome thank you
i'm just firing these questions away at
you right now thank you
um someone else asks who can access our
studio connect in your organization
so we um right now we protect it by a
two-factor uh environment in the azure
cloud so any kpmg
practitioners can access it um
eventually we're looking at uh getting
to the point of managed service or
something like that
but it's right now kpmg employees
let's see another question was how
difficult or easy is the testing given
the very nature of microservices so for
example with the distributed environment
um relatively easy so um in the
distributed environment um
there's still a url that is assigned to
each one of your service
um
all you have to do is know that url and
what um
if it's an if it's like a restful api so
you would need to know that url um and
the the verb that you would use so we
get requests or put requests
postman does a pretty fantastic job of
letting you
kind of
set those those tests and also create a
collection and share that with the rest
of your team too
but you just need to know those two
pieces of information and then
from the user perspective
you don't need to know where it is it
just
it's there
so relatively
relatively straightforward
cool thank you
david i see you just put a question
into the chat and
um but when you decided to go the micro
service route what was your first step
in building that architecture
so i think bijan you and i flew down to
austin and we got into a white boarding
session together to talk about what
what is the approach how how how do we
implement the uh microservices within
our application architecture how does it
overlap with our code and version
control management and our continuous
integration continuous deployment and
what did that look like as as a
portfolio so the first bit was is
understanding where our challenges were
uh we in the application development as
we're working in this case of coda
we're trying to do a lot more noticing
that there was a lot more
bugs that were happening development
timelines were harder to plan for
and just you could
as as somebody who's programmed myself
in my history you could tell it's just
it was getting very difficult for the
team to navigate forward even though the
team was entirely dedicated to the
project so understanding where those
challenges were really allowed us to
have a very productive conversation
about how to implement microservices in
a way that was designed to benefit the
team and not just to do something a
little bit different from there in terms
of implementing the microservices
themselves bijan and and this is where
you touch on in
in your area about uh
domain driven design on this of
then designing those microservices
within the application that that makes
sense what becomes interesting and now
we are starting to tap within our team
is within within a given application
there's domains that you can think about
how it works in the application but now
we have several related applications
that might reuse some of the
microservices that were originally built
in other applications so there's this
sort of meta domain that we're now
considering of this application does
something interesting or
something that we want to consume from
how that interlap with this application
that sits over there so now we're having
that that conversation of design around
the entire portfolio hopefully that
helped answer the question
okay um i had a question i wanted to ask
the team because i heard you were hiring
and i'm just curious to know a little
bit more about what roles you're hiring
for
so as i mentioned we're growing large
we're at 45 individuals now across
four different countries uh
predominantly in the united states and
right now we're hiring for a machine
learning engineer so we're looking for
somebody who actually has a good
understanding of the technology for
instance of what we talked about today
and how to implement that uh and how to
continue to implement this technology
across the team and also somebody with
the mathematical optimization knowledge
and background as our team does a lot of
mathematical optimization projects and
by joining this team what you tend to
work on both is the analytical problem
set such as how do i optimize routes or
paths but then try to figure out well
how do i turn that into
a data and analytics product and
technology so we take those case
problems and we turn that into
applications and solutions and we like
to use the word solutions because we do
develop web applications but sometimes
our solutions are apis
libraries and other ways for them to be
able to consume information so
that's our current posting that we have
now uh we can share that uh probably in
the chat window or some way uh but it's
a machine learning engineer with kpmg
and we're all we always will have new
positions that will be open up in the
near future so do keep an eye out for
that
awesome yeah feel free to share the link
in the chat window there too
i'll do that bijan
bijan i i see
um abdul aziz and apologies if i
mispronounce your name asked a question
in slido that said may you suggest some
web service
servers that host r based services or
python
i would suggest r studio connect um
that's
it took a lot of the um
understanding of the infrastructure away
from our team uh we didn't need to know
uh we didn't need to set up load bound
load balancing alone was was a big
concern of ours when we started this
because if you're requesting in and
to an api and you have other users
requesting to that same api you don't
want that one it's a single threaded
process so you don't want that one thing
to be blocking the other users
our studio connect does a fantastic job
of this
we've scaled it up to 100 concurrent
users and not run into an issue
um
so
right now we're
on a a virtual machine running our
studio connect and i don't see that
going away i think that's a great way to
get started because it it takes a lot of
the need to understand the
infrastructure side away from you you
publish and you're in a great position
that's awesome and i did not set up that
question or pay you to say that
awesome one other question was are
applications built with microservices as
responsive as those that adopt a
monolithic architecture or do
microservices and introduce a lag
so a very good question that one of the
benefits of hosting it within the rcu
connect environment is that there's
little latency between those two because
the apis in the front end are sitting in
the same physical location you could
have latency introduced if you were to
have servers sitting over here that were
hosting apis and then a front end that
was sitting somewhere else because you
then have to rely on the slowest part of
an application which is which is the
network or the internet trying to
communicate uh across all of that so
right now yes absolutely it's just as
responsive if not more so
because we're not taking
one set of code r
then using that to write a different
language usually javascript that is then
trying to process through the browser or
the interpreter which that was
introducing a lot of latency of
is it the code is it something else is
it the server is it the browser i can't
tell you how can't tell you how many
times we had questions trying to figure
out it's like
when it was just all monolithic like
okay what's causing what's causing the
latency issues here it's just been a lot
cleaner so there's not a lot of latency
because they're
those two bits are sitting right next to
each other and then all the bits of code
are doing exactly what they're supposed
to and not trying to do seven
seven different things at the same time
so it's been a lot better
cool thank you um the question was
can you show the backend response data
through developer tools
yeah um let me see
um
okay so this is the um i just made the
request to generate this chart um behind
the screen here but this is uh
this is the the exact response of the
data so we have
um in in my case i just have the uh the
manager id and um their designation
um
and then
uh it is just a simple array of all
manager ids uh and designations
underneath it
um
you know not nothing nothing too uh
dramatic um we could take a look at this
one as well so um these are this is the
metadata um that would actually pop up
uh on a different um
a different area and then uh
here we have org statistics and our
organization so um
this uh
this is the data that's populating um
the kind of cards that i like if i hover
over it um there's information here um
so that information is all
encapsulated in these these json json
structures
um so a couple of requests were made um
behind the scenes um back-ends for
front-ends is two of those three
requests um and then this one is for the
radio the chart that we're looking at
there i hope that answers your question
or if there was apollo i'm happy to
speak to them
that's great thank you
i see one last question on slido
and rahul asked can you speak more about
the logging microservice did you build
it ground up did you adopt an
off-the-shelf package or app
we used two services really one of them
is used for our
infrastructure monitoring and network
monitoring so that that is an
off-the-shelf um service
but for our applications because we're
building these completely from scratch
we use our own
service
and it's a relatively simple
activity-based uh logging where you know
if an error happens we log that error if
a warning happens we log the warning if
it's just a simple request it's an
information
log
so to answer your question
both
but yeah
awesome well thank you so much tom and
bijan
for the awesome presentation that was
great and appreciate all the awesome
questions as well
thank you thank you for having us
thank you everybody have a great rest of
the day
[Music]